one other news thing that happened on
Nick Cannon came to the aid of Kevin
Hart Kevin Hart got reprimanded he got
asked to emcee the one of these award
shows that you know it's um they give
awards to you know it's companies that
give awards to actors that they own
basically a lot of times so you'll see
uh you know it's like oh the Academy but
it's all tied in together and it's all
owned by the same companies or supported
by the same company so it's all a bunch
of [ __ ] a lot of times it's a lot of
rich people award another rich people I
find but also could be angry because
they've never given me meena me nothing
but the UM
now Kevin Hart what he did was he got
asked to hostess Awards Oscars and then
they went through his tweets and said
well he said homophobic stuff in the
past and now he needs to apologize for
it and he told him to [ __ ] off basically
he did but then he did apologize but
also told him to [ __ ] off that he didn't
want to do it and I commend him you know
I commend him for that
I don't think if five or six people on
Twitter get angry about something then
that's to justify everyone and the more
that that kind of stuff keeps happening
and that the media really caters to
those small voices just to create
controversy the more you're making the
masses angry I think because their
voices aren't heard not only not heard
but not respected and so Nick Cannon
came to his aid and made fun of other
you know retweeted old things that other
people had tweeted in the past you know
you know called out Amy Schumer Sarah
Silverman and Chelsea Handler you know
three Jewish comedians that were I guess
I've been allowed to host shows even
though that they called people [ __ ] in
past tweets and good for him man good
for somebody be able to say something
you know I think you need a black guy to
say
something I think if a white guy bring
this brings this up they wouldn't even
let this be an article so I'm happy that
you know that people are standing up for
their friends in the industry and that
finally people are saying oh well it's
interesting that these three white women
can behave a certain way but but this
man it doesn't have some of the same
freedoms so good for Kevin you know good
for Kevin man you know it's not fair
that you know you have a lot of these
you know and but all three of these
women condescending you know you know
these are all women who you know to me
make fun of the rest of America and look
down upon those people who are less
fortunate than them and believe they can
tell people how to vote and how to
behave just because they have money a
lot of extreme white privilege with
these women you know so good for them
good for those guys standing up against
against basically what's not you know
you want equality you got to treat
people equal and [ __ ] these boring-ass
Oscar who gives a [ __ ] half the movies
they pick always suck dick anyway done
Kirk's the only good movie I've seen in
the past five years but anyhow that's
just my thoughts and I can be totally
now it could be totally wrong Wow you
know it's crazy as my sister can't even
read but what does it have to do with us
right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one guess what